hello good morning and welcome to
gamespot presents the mix right here at
GDC 2015 I'm your host Daniel Dwyer on
over the next two hours we have a bunch
of indie games to show you in fact so
many indie games that I'm not going to
do any more introducing some time gone
tell you my friend good haters and
pleasure to have you here first game up
and this is a game that a couple of
weeks ago we saw the trailer for here at
gamespot and they basically every video
producer crowded round one screen and
then pissed ourselves a strafe as a big
sort of old school FPS bam there's a
game that I want to hear more about it
so tell us about it strafe is a old
school FPS and that's all we got no it's
a it's a procedural generated FPS you so
we offer the rooms we're making an
experience but you can like the goals to
endlessly play it so it's you know has
roguelike elements basically I just
really love doing too I love quake I
love spelunky and I just wanted like
cram them together ok you got me that
quake and spelunky together and let's
hop right in because I know you guys
have obviously it was gameplay in the
trailer you guys had a early version yet
on Kickstarter for people to sort of
play themselves and this is a brand new
build right yeah so this is a speedrun
build this is a locked seed and
ultimately in the game when you start
out you're given three options as to
what primary weapon you want right we
have the shotgun the machine gun and the
railgun so with these weapons you're
going to carry these throughout the game
they won't be the only weapon you get
but you're gonna be able to upgrade them
as you go so they'll get more ridiculous
okay so you know your shotgun is your
basic shotgun and the secondary fires a
lot wider and it has the ability to
penetrate enemies the machine gun you
know your traditional bullet hose
secondary them explode nice and then the
railgun like a personal favorite yeah
check that we just put that smoke in
yeah and then all far you can charge it
up yeah I don't stop Unreal Tournament
shock rifle style baby nice alright gay
so i'm gonna go the machine gun cuz i
suck at my own game here's this photo
realistic vista skyboxes might take that
bungee
it's beautiful oh okay now if I can use
the stairs guys I shouldn't it's a live
demo you should we took the first thing
on a monday morning and so this is the
hub lion here you know you'll choose
your weapon you know we introduced the
idea of like the food dispensers here in
the full game this will be access to
other play modes excellence and you jump
through here to the crashed ship Icarus
where you'll start the game so in the
speedrun you just kill stuff and get to
the exit so this is super early people
should know as well baby game isn't even
thirty percent done so I'm probably
gonna dialogue because don't worry yeah
the last thing we need is another super
easy first person shooter so don't worry
about it my friend and this so this is a
single-player only game i'm assuming
this is you're not going down the line
of trying to we don't know make
multiplayer deathmatch shooters this is
that this is very much a in the spelunky
style of playing it over and over and
over and over and right so we'll have
competitive modes where you could like
almost like a daily challenge we can
lock to see brunch and then have people
compete against each other we are
entertaining the idea so off right now
it's really so limited in size for ice
but as far as like def match and any
modes where you're competing we we don't
want to compete with quake because quake
is too great i play anything yeah and
you know also that's kind of it you know
tried and tested at this stage like the
multiplayer there are enough multiplayer
like arena shooters even there like this
sort of weird resurgence we've seen in
the past year or so like even quite
Clive is struggling a bit like the two
of us were talking beforehand about how
we were playing it but like not many
people play that anymore what you seem
to be guys see be making here is like
latching onto the sort of super popular
roguelike worlds and then crafting a you
know a sean redoute has been you know
much maligned in the past couple years
well we're you know we're making it cuz
we love it i think yeah roblox are very
popular right now but that's definitely
not the reason we we jumped into it you
know was a love of spelunky and was a
love of just that the court gameplay
come wake you know just like picking it
up the real tight control if you build
it the air straight like it feels great
so to be able to jump in and just have
oh man I like I these guys fall over I
like these sort of weird it's like it's
got a real quick to vibe to it and then
you shoot them and they just flop over
all nasty ya know they will shred them
up it's great when you guys looking to
get this out I know you've had your
Kickstarter you had your trailer and
there is our version like you said
earlier about when you'll it's just uh
you know this is definitely a real rough
pre-alpha speedrun build but later this
year we intend to release a shareware
version so you can just accelerate the
first few left oh you guys are really
leaning into this hard I like it let's
grab these steroids back around a lot
faster and then I'm oh it's like UFC and
then with will probably release the game
and um we're trying to go for early 2016
okay but we're gonna a definite let the
game dictate what it needs to be because
there's nothing worse than rushing a
game out Tabitha and one of the most
critical parts of any like successful
arena shooters level design so how do
you guys have you guys like coping with
that alongside your procedural the
procedural nature of these levels um eat
your food man oh man broken broken it's
really early guys and ladies okay I'll
explain that to you um right here once I
house but isn't it the best of it live
demos man you got a whole week of this
look forward to trying to player this is
what this is a time of which like we
have developers in and they wish they
made an easier game yeah like you see
the Dark Souls guys they don't do live
demo that way too hard okay so the one
thing is um all the Gibbs in the game oh
whoa whoa you're putting the line down
there Oh jibs you got what are you going
for you got a night I said state your
claim when I heard I think Romero in the
original team said it was jibs giblets
so I have to listen to the you know to
him I'm a [ __ ] phone so no I'm happy
with that um so yeah it's all persistent
and this is stuff that you know if it
hits the ceiling it'll drip down on
walls little run down like this is just
the first version of the hmm but we want
to use it as a sense of ownership of the
environment as well as giving you a
breadcrumb trail to like okay I've been
in the space you're not going to run
through an empty room and what you know
like really get annoyed so as far as how
procida generations work I will you know
use this room as an example mmm here's a
potential door and we can like child
pickups enemies different things to that
so if this was shut down we could have
like a scrap bench here you know items
for you to you
I'm standing an acid the aggressive for
you to standing oh yeah i'll explain
that in a second these walls will
disappear in theirs doors that spawn
behind them and there's like six
different entry points so this room has
been authored yeah for you to like
basically have a fun experience you can
like you know play around and it's in
this beam enemies can get stuck in it
that'll kill you to go into it so it's
like a fun little set piece do you run
into problems where you've like spawns
20 dudes into a tiny little room full of
Craig bowels and [ __ ] but it's just
going to make it impossible to live um
not yeah but I think I definitely think
we're gonna run into that issue what's a
photo the big issue we run into in a fun
way like I don't I don't know how to say
it otherwise it's like this orange stuff
is it comes out of some enemies and then
it's acid we treat it kind of like the
blood from alien yeah so when you its
last applied so if I were to kill this
button right here and his blood is now
covering up so in the full game you'll
be able to like pick up corpses and
throw them at asset if you're stuck in a
greater I like it it's been sorely
missed from first-person shooters how
far you from the end here we are I will
see how you see everything do you think
you can do it I probably I'm going slow
enough whoa look who's out dude that's
the stalker those guys they'll try to
find good vantage points away from you
and then just lob projectiles at you so
that we kind of we love shmups too so
being able to just fill a room with
projectile so that you can dance through
and as also our power ups that's pretty
good you'll shoot them and you don't
have to slow down I three design
decisions are basically keeping the game
fast and that's broken and them so we
want to be able to keep the game faster
you can run through it we want to fill
the game with secrets and just make it
as gory as possible so
excellently seems to have succeeded on
those at least at the in this this early
version as this your guys first game
you're making yep that's because your
background is in is in and for anyone
you've seen the trailer this makes
complete sense but your background is in
the editing or directing or and
directing music business my music videos
and commercials so what made you want to
get into the crazy world of games
development I've been mapping since I
was a kid oh really like it's it's one
of those things where it's always been a
hobby you know okay in college it was
you know your friends were playing quake
um half-life 2 just came out at that
point so as you know probably have like
death match yet playing hammer let's
start playing with hammers yeah you know
when I forget what it tech it was but
when doom free came out I really fell in
love with that it or because it was a
lot easier to work with but yeah ended
up mapping a lot really falling in love
with it and then when I found out that a
friend of mine was able to program and
actually really great at it I've been
waiting like years for this spelunky
beats quick style games like we'll just
make it ourselves so the yeah you got
impatience and the sort of stars aligned
with your friend and no hmm so exit door
this is the exit door and intently moves
very slow so that if you'da cut if you
were to kite enemies here yes you back
up you have to fight them and then when
the spark launches you know you can
figure out it's alright and then you
lock your time by hitting the console
Albright um so then you upload your x to
the server and these are all our hi
Scott I still based on the three
different guns yeah that's the sort of
speeds own version of strafe obviously
the potential version will be coming and
once the the game is released it would
be completely wrong of me to have you
here the creative mind behind that
ridiculous trailer without showing some
of that ridiculous trailer ok so I think
we we have a look at it now at what was
the idea behind this because it to me it
was an indie studio you expect a certain
level quality for the trailer and maybe
this would be like you know for Triple A
game it would look something this
fantastical but like head how did you
guys come up with this concept I was the
cost it costs less than fifteen hundred
dollars oh my god we ended up shooting
all of this in my programmer Stevens
like dining room we went to his house he
emptied it out we feel
with stuff from his childhood his mom's
kind of a pack rat so she just kept all
that stuff is legitimate and then we
bought a desk in a computer from
craigslist and just fill the space
that's ridiculous I think you can if you
hit is this your machine you know we hit
play on it is that nope uh yeah and it's
just you know we were making straight
because we love these these older games
and I you know I love to direct I love
to make videos so it was just merging
the two things we love who is this kid
um actors we found look like really yeah
we shot this in Pittsburgh did anyone
care that you were going to cover their
children in in blood and especially the
smaller child not to smaller for anyone
but I was very worried about that so I I
clarified multiple times with the
parents beforehand I'm like we're gonna
make this cheesy we're gonna make it as
fun as possible on set so it's not dark
and like your scarring your kid yeah but
yeah they went very cool let's just let
the let's just let it run let's pump up
the volume on this and just enjoy it for
everyone who's watching the stream
for live life get the morning death
hmm
just so people know
Oh God take it this is my favorite part
cherry coke cherry coke like yeah this
is my favorite part this will fit oh oh
you can't handle damage x gameplay is
pretty great line there you go strafe
coming I guess we'll see more of it
later this year coming 2016 and anyone
can check out this trailer themselves
and after GDC we're going to be
releasing the speed the speed run build
a new version so that anyone can
download it anyone can have fun with it
and just try to like get on the top of
the high score board fantastic don't
thank you so much really appreciate it
enjoy the rest of GCC actually will be
wrong for me to make you leave it at
showing the back of your sick jacket if
you like you're throwing about it if you
like 90s games there you go look at that
just ridiculous let's see it's not like
sprayed on yeah it's airbrush airbrush
wonderful